krebse muscheln und seesterne insgesamt
rund 10.000 tier und pflanzenarten leben
hier im rhythmus der gezeiten bei watt
führungen könnt ihr diesen lebensraum
erforschen
eine faszinierende welt die seit 2009
zum unesco weltnaturerbe gehört auch die
salzwiesen und sandbänke gehören zur
schutzzone das highlight aber ist ein
besuch bei den seehunden den
beliebtesten bewohnern des watts
ausflugsboote bringen euch ganz nah ran
an die scheuen tiere
das solltet ihr nicht verpassen um diese
natur in ihrer vielfalt zu erhalten
wurden schon vor mehr als 30 jahren
große teile norderney es zum
nationalpark erklärt die insulaner waren
erst einmal nicht so begeistert das hat
auch eine ganze zeit gedauert aber
misstrauen sicherlich auf beiden seiten
die wollen nur ihren tourismus wir
wollen nur ihren naturschutz
aber das hat sich dann doch anschließend
sehr schnell angeblich mittlerweile ist
das wattenmeer längst teil des
touristischen konzept ranger des
nationalparks machen besucher mit den
waldbewohnern bekannt zb dem strand floh
wir leben auf den meeresboden graben
sich ein und können sich über ihre
pigmente also diese punkte ein bisschen
dunkler färben und zum ersten mal auf
dem rad und ziemlich sprachlos was was
man da alles finden können traumhaft
irgendwo wir kommen auf jeden fall
wieder
ich bin doch lustig durch den schlick zu
laufen und dieses leckere wie heißt das
salz gras zu essen ist sehr toll und
spannend und plötzlich sehen die
besucher nicht nur schlick und schlamm
sondern erkennen zusammenhänge
das ist genau das was die ranger
erreichen wollen
hier muss man eher sehr genau hingucken
man muss sehr feinen daran gehen um zu
erkennen was für eine vielfalt hier
herrscht sie ist nicht so offensichtlich
und nicht so pompös wie in den tropen
aber sie kann wenn man genauer hinguckt
genauso begeistern ist genauso schön
wenn alles gut läuft sind die gäste bei
ihrer abreise achtsamer und haben mehr
respekt für die landschaft in der sie
urlaub machen